.
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
Ich war früher skeptisch und sagte,
das sei Unsinn.
Das könne nicht sein.
Wenn fertig ist, sei fertig.
Nach den Erlebnissen,
die ich hatte, muss ich sagen,
dass ich überzeugt davon bin,
dass es nach dem Tod weitergeht.
Ich habe das sehr lange
niemandem erzählt.
Man wird automatisch
in eine Schiene reingedrängt.
Ich hatte Angst davor,
in eine spirituelle,
esoterische oder religiöse Schiene
gedrängt zu werden,
in die ich gar nicht gehöre.
Ich erwachte plötzlich -
aus einer tiefen Bewusstlosigkeit.
Mit diesem hohen, feierlichen
Gefühl, das sehr durchdringend war:
"Ich sterbe. Ich bin am Sterben."
Ich wurde sofort glücklich.
Schon allein das Licht
war so vertraut,
also, diese lichtgefüllte Umgebung.
Es fühlte sich nach Heimkommen an.
Was ich erlebt habe,
ist so viel grösser als das,
was wir uns vorstellen können.
Ich möchte nicht sagen,
dass ich Gott gesehen habe,
aber einen Glanz von ihm.
Was passiert, wenn wir sterben?
Davon berichten Menschen, die
mit einem Fuss im Jenseits standen.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Sy mir zäme scho mal gschtorbe?
# U wider inenang gebore?
# Und heys bis hüt nur vergässe?
# Sy mir uf dr Ärde gläge?
# Hey üs d'Frage gschtellt vom Läbe?
# Üs dr wyt Himmu
u dr glych Atem teilt?
Marcel Gasser ist Materialwart
beim Erstliga-Verein EHC Burgdorf.
So will er dem Eishockey
verbunden bleiben.
Minder.
Marcel Gasser war ein
vielversprechendes Eishockeytalent.
Er träumte davon,
Profisportler zu werden.
Dann hatte er mit Anfang 20
einen Motorradunfall.
Danach war alles anders.
Ich musste merken,
dass ich durch den schweren Unfall
Gleichgewichtsprobleme hatte
und dass ich das Schlittschuhlaufen
und all das
nicht mehr
auf dem Niveau machen kann.
Ich musste die Hockeykarriere
dann leider an den Nagel hängen.
Und? Hast du ein Goal gemacht?
- Nein.
Nicht?
Konntest du nie schiessen?
Das nächste Mal
machst du wieder Goals, oder?
Dass er fast gestorben wäre,
hat Marcel Gasser verändert.
Er sei achtsamer geworden,
lebe intensiver
und mache sich nützlich, wo er könne.
Ich hatte das Glück, dass ich
zurück auf die Erde kommen konnte.
Es wurde mir quasi
das Leben geschenkt.
Ich sehe das heute als Geschenk an.
Ich versuche einfach,
so glücklich wie möglich zu leben.
Der ist kleben geblieben.
Sein Lebenstraum
platzte mit Anfang 20.
Trotzdem
mag er mit Ende 40 nicht klagen.
Wieso auch?
Er sei ja am Leben - immerhin.
Sind Sie ein glücklicher Mensch?
- Ja.
Ja ... Glück ...
Ich bin zufrieden mit meinem Leben.
Was passiert ist, gehört zu mir.
Also, ich hadere nicht
mit meinem Schicksal.
Im Gegenteil,
das hat mich stärker gemacht.
Der Unfall ist fast 30 Jahre her,
aber die Erinnerungen daran leben.
Ich war wie an der Decke oben,
hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ich sah mich im Bett.
Ich sah, wie die Ärzte drückten,
Spritzen und Schläuche setzten.
Ich sah alles.
Ich fragte mich, was ich hier mache.
Es war extrem komisch. Ich war hier
und sah mich dort liegen.
Was soll das?
Ich hatte das Gefühl ...
... ich würde mich lösen,
Faser um Faser,
von allem, was mir lieb ist.
Dann kam ich plötzlich
in eine Art Strudel.
Und dann in einen gewaltigen Sog,
der mich fortriss.
Wie ein Fluss.
Es gab in mir einen Moment,
in dem ...
... etwas in meinem Körper
zum Stillstand kam.
Es waren wie Zahnräder -
als wäre ich ein Uhrwerk.
Und plötzlich rastete das ein.
Etwas zog an mir.
Nicht am Körper,
sondern wie an meinem ganzen Wesen.
So fühlte sich das an.
Dann machte es plötzlich klick und
ich merkte, dass ich am Sterben bin.
Dann brach in mir Panik aus.
Und dann kämpfte ich. Ich gab alles.
Aber ich merkte, dass ich
nicht stärker bin als diese Kraft.
Franz Dschulnigg war Kadermann
in einer kantonalen Verwaltung.
Seit seiner Frühpensionierung
widmet er sich dem Überirdischen.
Das Thema Jenseits
und Leben nach dem Tod
ist eigentlich eine Frage,
die jeden Einzelnen betrifft.
Es ist eine existenzielle Frage.
Und es ist auch eine Frage,
die mich seit meiner Jugend
schon immer sehr interessierte.
Das ist auch der Grund dafür,
warum ich jetzt
Jenseitsforschung betreibe.
Er selber hatte nie
eine Nahtoderfahrung,
aber er hat
schon Dutzende von Menschen besucht,
die fast gestorben wären.
Menschen wie Magdalen Bless.
Mit seiner Videoausrüstung
zeichnet er die Gespräche auf.
Das Ergebnis veröffentlicht
Franz Dschulnigg im Internet.
Daran verdient er nichts.
Er möchte, dass sich viele
mit dem Thema befassen können.
Wenn man in die Ferien geht,
kümmert man sich ja auch
um das Land, in das man reist -
um sich unschöne Überraschungen
zu ersparen.
Aus dem gleichen Grund sollte
man sich mit dem Jenseits befassen.
Frau Bless, Sie erlebten im Alter
von 20 Jahren eine Nahtoderfahrung.
Wie kam das?
Ich war unterwegs mit meinem Vater.
In seinem Auto. Er war am Steuer.
Wir fuhren nach Hause.
Da kam
mit grosser Geschwindigkeit ...
... von der gegenüberliegenden Seite
- also uns entgegen - ein Auto.
Rund 5 % der Menschen
machen im Laufe ihres Lebens
eine sog. Nahtoderfahrung,
aber nur wenige reden darüber.
Das Thema anzuschneiden
ist sehr heikel.
Man kann schnell als Spinner oder so
abgestempelt werden,
als unglaubwürdig
abgestempelt werden.
Es ist schon noch schwierig,
offen darüber sprechen zu können.
Da ist auch die Angst, sich nicht
verständlich machen zu können.
Wir haben ...
... gar keine Verbalität für das.
Ich habe erst angefangen darüber
zu sprechen, als ich über 20 war.
Die Erfahrung machte ich mit acht.
Es war mir peinlich.
Ich glaube,
der Tod an sich ist ein Tabu.
In unserer Gesellschaft.
Das stimmt, ja.
Das ...
... ist ein Thema,
das man lieber ausblendet.
Warum das so ist?
Es macht einfach Angst.
Es machte auch mir immer Angst -
bis zu dem Erlebnis.
Franz Dschulnigg
hat ein weiteres Interview im Kasten.
Einmal mehr
wurde ihm das Ende des Lebens
als wunderschön geschildert.
Insgesamt bemühe ich mich immer ...
... Personen zu finden,
die negative Erfahrungen hatten.
Es gelingt mir ...
Man findet sozusagen fast keine.
Zehntausende,
teilweise gar Hunderttausende
schauen sich
Franz Dschulniggs Interviews an.
Interviews mit Menschen, die
mit einem Fuss im Jenseits standen,
interessieren offenbar.
Jeder hat verstorbene Angehörige.
Wenn er weiss, dass die Verstorbenen
in der geistigen Welt
gut empfangen werden,
dass sie betreut werden,
dass es ihnen gut geht ...
... ist das für die Hinterbliebenen
auch ein Trost und eine Hilfe.
Im Prinzip ist es eine Lebenshilfe.
Es ist ein sich wiederholendes
Element in den Erfahrungsberichten:
Der Sterbende
bleibe nicht lange allein.
Plötzlich
kamen mir Gestalten entgegen ...
... die ich ... äh ...
... kannte.
Sie hiessen mich wie willkommen.
Zuvorderst
kam meine Grossmutter daher -
ganz strahlend
und glücklich und leuchtend.
Dann nahm ich plötzlich
eine Bewegung wahr,
rechts von meinem Bett.
Ich drehte den Kopf und dann ...
... sass jemand neben meinem Bett.
Ein junger Mann.
Aber er war nicht menschlich.
Er war ganz ätherisch.
Wie ausgefüllt mit Licht.
Ich sah die Gestalten
und hatte sofort eine Erinnerung.
Ich wusste, wer das ist.
Nicht, dass ich es in Worten
erklären könnte, wer das war,
aber ich fühlte es.
Als hätte ich
meine Familie wiedergefunden.
Ich kannte ihn.
Ich hatte ihn noch nie gesehen,
aber ich kannte ihn.
Es war ein tiefes Erkennen.
Dann ...
... begannen wir,
miteinander zu kommunizieren.
Nicht mental oder telepathisch,
auch nicht verbal, sondern ...
... irgendwie von hier aus,
vom Herzen aus.
Eine Kommunikation, die wir
auf dieser Welt nicht kennen.
Am besten könnte man das wie
einen Energieaustausch beschreiben.
Es floss etwas.
Sein Wesen und mein Wesen
tauschten sich aus.
Es floss etwas hin und her.
Und während das floss,
verstand ich immer mehr
über die Welt und die Liebe
und über den Sinn in allem.
Ich konnte immer mehr loslassen.
Ich verstand, dass alles gut ist.
Plötzlich sah ich mein ganzes Leben
noch einmal vor mir ablaufen -
ganz schnell.
Alles fast zugleich.
Fast wie in einer Kugel.
Das Nächste, was passierte, war,
dass sich meine Beziehungen
auffächerten.
Sie lagen vor mir
wie ein aufgefächertes Kartenspiel.
Es wurde so klar,
dass alle Beziehungen
in meinem Leben einen Sinn haben,
auch wenn sie nur ganz kurz waren.
Normalerweise
fährt man wie in einer Bobbahn:
Man hat so zwei Wände links
und rechts und man fährt einfach.
Aber jetzt plötzlich
sah ich darüber hinaus.
Ich sah Zusammenhänge,
die ich vorher nicht sah.
Wil im Kanton St. Gallen.
Hierher hat es die promovierte
Historikerin Magdalen Bless
immer wieder gezogen.
Sie hat die Geschichte dieser Stadt
studiert
und vieles darüber geschrieben.
Fragen des Glaubens
haben sie zeitlebens beschäftigt.
Die rund 850 Jahre alte Wiler Madonna
etwa fasziniert sie noch heute.
Eine sagenumwobene Kultfigur,
die immer wieder
Wunder vollbracht haben soll.
Was glauben Sie persönlich?
Ich glaube,
dass Liebe und Weisheit ...
... die Grundprinzipien ...
... der Schöpfung des Menschen,
des Kosmos, von allem sind.
Und das ist zusammengefasst ...
... in dem, was wir "Gott" nennen.
Es ist ein geistiges Prinzip.
Unfassbar.
Aber es ist da
und wirkt sich immer aus.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ihr halbes Forscherleben
hat Magdalen Bless
den bestens erhaltenen historischen
Quellen von Wil gewidmet.
Sie fand Erfüllung im Eintauchen
in längst vergangene Zeiten.
Und sie teilte ihre Passion
stets gerne.
Es ist der sog. Grosse Vertrag
von 1492 ...
Etwa mit den Zuschauern
des inzwischen eingestellten
Wiler Stadtfernsehens.
Darin
war das ganze Stadtrecht festgelegt.
Es war ein Stadtrecht,
das den Wilern
eine weitgehende Autonomie gewährte.
Man versteht die Gegenwart besser,
wenn man die Entwicklungsstränge
kennt,
wenn man weiss,
wie was entstanden ist.
Wir sind immer noch
nur auf den Schultern
der vorherigen Generationen.
Und diese auch wieder
auf den Schultern derer vor ihnen.
Vieles lebt bewusst
oder unbewusst weiter.
Und vieles
versteht man in der Welt besser,
wenn man die Geschichte kennt.
Je mehr man kennt, desto kleiner
werden die Mosaiksteine,
die man zusammensetzen kann.
Vieles
versteht man mit der Zeit besser.
Und vieles bleibt ein Mysterium.
Irgendwo sah ich ganz leicht
ein weisses Pünktchen.
Und ich versuchte krampfhaft,
zu diesem weissen Punkt zu kommen.
Ich wollte wissen, was dort ist.
Es gab eine Rückwärtsbewegung.
Dann bin ich so - puff ...
... in einem Lichtmeer aufgegangen.
Diese Zellexplosion war so ...
Das war wie ein Jubelschrei.
Es war viel mehr als ein Licht.
Es strömte
eine unglaubliche Wärme ...
... und Liebe aus.
Und eine unglaubliche Weisheit
und ein Wissen.
Es war der Inbegriff des Absoluten.
Es war ein lebendiges,
pulsierendes, mehrschichtiges Licht.
Ich kann es nicht anders erklären:
wie eine Symphonie.
Das Licht war lebendig.
Es vibrierte vor lauter Energie.
Eine ganz subtile Energie ...
... und Kreativität.
Heute würde ich sagen,
dass es reines Sein war.
Ich war nur noch.
Es gibt keine Worte. Schöpfung ...
Ich weiss es nicht.
Einfach absolutes,
liebevolles Bewusstsein.
Es war so pures Glück,
ein Teil davon zu sein.
Ein Seminarzentrum
in der Nähe von Wien.
Gut, wir starten mit Vollatmung.
Wir nehmen uns richtig schön Zeit.
Ramon Gartmann sagt,
er sei Lebenscoach.
Er helfe Menschen,
in Gruppen oder einzeln,
ihr einzigartiges
und wunderschönes Wesen zu entdecken
und die Furcht vor ihren Schatten
und ihrem Licht zu verlieren.
* Die Teilnehmer
machen verschiedene Geräusche. *
Ohne seine intensive Nahtoderfahrung
undenkbar.
Es ist das Verständnis darüber,
was ich ganz tief innen bin,
hinter den Bildern und den Worten,
die ich über mich habe.
Das ist eine spirituelle Erfahrung,
eine tiefe Selbstbegegnung.
Die brauchte es
in der Nahtoderfahrung,
damit ich den Weg gehen konnte,
um im praktischen Leben
herauszufinden, wie man dahin kommt.
Das brauchte es.
* Spiritueller Gesang *
In diesem mehrtägigen Kurs,
einem sog. Retreat,
sollen die Teilnehmerinnen
laut Gartmann zur Ruhe kommen,
sich selbst begegnen und die Magie
ihrer inneren Welt erleben.
Wir verstecken uns im Leben
sehr viel hinter einer Maske,
weil wir tief in uns nicht glauben,
dass wir schön genug sind,
um uns einfach zu zeigen,
wie wir sind.
Dann so dazuliegen
und beklungen zu werden,
und dann auch dieser Moment,
wenn man aufmachen
und das zulassen kann,
ist wieder ein Kontakt
mit meiner Schönheit.
In dem Moment
konnte ich einfach akzeptieren,
dass ich schön bin -
wie alle anderen.
Er wolle mithelfen, die Welt
ein bisschen besser zu machen,
eine Welt, in die er nach seinem
12 m tiefen Sturz von einem Dach
im Alter von acht Jahren
eigentlich gar nicht zurückwollte.
Dann sagte er,
es sei Zeit zurückzugehen.
Und ich sagte:
"Nein, ich gehe nicht zurück."
Dann sagte er:
"Es ist deine Entscheidung."
"Aber ich möchte dir etwas zeigen,
bevor du dich entscheidest."
Dann nahm er mich mit.
Es fühlte sich an, als würden wir
durch einen Vorhang gehen.
Dann waren wir wieder
in dieser physischen Welt.
Plötzlich überlegte ich mir ...
... was ich der Erde hinterlasse.
Also, wenn ich jetzt gehe:
Was lasse ich zurück?
Ich merkte,
dass ich nichts zurücklasse.
Ich hinterlasse
keinen Stempel von mir.
Und in diesem wunderbaren Moment ...
... dieser glutvollen Begegnung
mit diesem Licht ...
... stockte plötzlich der Fluss,
in dem ich mitgezogen wurde.
Und ich hörte ein störendes Wort:
meinen Namen.
Und ich merkte,
dass mein Vater mich ruft.
Ich erkannte seine Stimme.
Ich merkte, dass er
in höchster Verzweiflung war,
in Panik.
Plötzlich spürte ich eine Hand
auf meiner Schulter.
Dann schaute ich rüber.
Es war mein Vater,
der vor gut 20 Jahren gestorben war.
Wie man ihn kannte: Hemd,
Krawatte, Anzug, gekämmtes Haar.
Und er sagte: "Was machst du da?"
Dann sagte ich:
"Ich hatte einen Unfall."
Ja ... "Ich bin hier."
"Was soll ich machen?"
Dann sagte er zu mir: "Deine Zeit
ist noch nicht gekommen."
"Du musst zurück.
Wir wollen dich noch nicht."
Ich lag im Krankenwagen und sah mich
aus der Vogelperspektive.
Ich sah die Sanitäter,
wie sie probierten, mich ...
Wie sie sich um mich kümmerten,
versuchten, mich zu retten.
Dann richtete das Wesen
meine Aufmerksamkeit
auf den hinteren Teil
des Krankenwagens.
Beim Ausgang sass meine Mutter.
Dann sah ich ihren Schmerz ...
... und das, was durch meinen Tod
in ihr bricht.
In dem Moment
wünschte ich mir nichts sehnlicher,
als in das Licht einzutauchen.
Aber dann
spürte ich wieder seine Angst.
Ich stellte mir das plastisch vor,
dass in ein paar Tagen die Beerdi-
gung ist und alle weinen würden,
weil man bei einem jungen Menschen
mehr weint als bei einem alten.
Dann kam die Entscheidung in mir,
dass ich zurückwollte.
Und unmittelbar war ich - zack -
wieder im Körper drin.
Ich erwachte in meinem vom Unfall
völlig geschundenen Körper.
Nach einer Weile
erwachte ich aber wieder
in einem schaukelnden Gefährt.
Und dann ...
... hörte ich einen freundlichen
Menschen seine Pflicht tun.
Er fragte: "Wie heissen Sie?"
"Und bei welcher Krankenkasse
sind Sie?"
Dann musste ich so schmunzeln.
Eigentlich lachen,
weil ich dachte:
"Jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Jetzt hat die Erde mich wieder."
Andrea Pfeifer kam zurück ins Leben,
weil sie noch etwas zu teilen hatte
mit der Welt:
ihre Musik.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Sy mir zäme scho mal gschtorbe?
# U wider inenang gebore?
# Und heys bis hüt nur vergässe?
# Sy mir uf dr Ärde gläge?
# Hey üs d'Frage gschtellt vom Läbe?
# Üs dr wyt Himmu
u dr glych Atem teilt?
# Hey mir üse Wäg scho gha?
# Oder fat är a?
# Es isch egau.
Es verband mich
wie mit einer Mission.
Meine Musik und ich wurden wie eins.
Ich habe nicht mehr so Hemmungen,
damit nach aussen zu gehen,
weil ich weiss, dass das Gefühl,
das ich dort erlebt habe,
diese ganz tiefe Reue -
das möchte ich nie mehr erleben.
Das Endziel ist quasi, zurückschauen
zu können und zu wissen,
dass ich alles von mir gegeben habe.
Und das ist jetzt
schon viel mehr da.
Früher machte sie Musik,
war aber zu schüchtern,
damit an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen.
Heute spielt sie in einer Band
namens "Alva Lün" und tritt auf.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Sie vokalisiert eine Melodie. *
Dass sie beinahe an einer Lebens-
mittelvergiftung gestorben wäre,
hat alles verändert -
sogar ihre Wahrnehmung.
Ich sehe oft ...
... wenn ich jemandem begegne
und ihm in die Augen sehe,
dass das Gesicht sich verwandelt.
Ich sehe verschiedene ...
... "Inkarnationen".
Es klingt so esoterisch.
Aber ja,
ich sehe viele verschiedene Formen.
Das klingt crazy.
Wenn ich Sie jetzt ansehe,
sehe ich verschiedene Schichten
von Energien um Sie herum.
Die sind einfach da, wie ein
sehr transparentes Glas oder besser,
wie sehr transparentes Wasser,
das in Bewegung ist.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass ich ...
... intuitiver geworden bin.
V.a. in den ersten Jahren ...
... hatte ich manchmal Ahnungen,
die ich mir nicht erklären konnte.
Ich spüre das relativ schnell
im Bauch.
Plötzlich habe ich
Bauchschmerzen oder Bauchkrämpfe
oder es wird mir schlecht.
So Dinge.
Dann merke ich meistens,
dass irgendetwas ist,
dass etwas kommt
oder etwas passiert ist -
etwas,
das in meinem Umfeld sein könnte.
Franz Dschulnigg sammelt fleissig
weiter Interviews
für seinen YouTube-Kanal
namens
"Empirische Jenseitsforschung".
Diejenigen, die öffentlich über
ihre Blicke ins Jenseits redeten,
hätten eine gemeinsame Motivation,
sagt er.
Sie selber haben das erlebt,
dass sie liebevoll empfangen wurden,
dass sie ein wunderschönes Gefühl
hatten, als sie rüberkamen.
Das wollen sie
den anderen mitteilen:
dass man keine Angst haben muss.
Viele Schulmediziner
sind indes überzeugt,
dass es für solche Erfahrungen
ganz simple Erklärungen gebe:
etwa Sauerstoffmangel,
zu viel Kohlendioxid
oder chemische Reaktionen im Gehirn.
Ich kann jeden Zweifler
durchaus verstehen.
Ich bin eigentlich
auch eher ein kritischer Mensch.
Ich versuche auch niemanden
zu bekehren,
damit er etwas anderes glaubt.
Aber es ist kein Ding des Hirns.
Ich glaube, wenn man es erlebt hat,
fallen diese Fragen einfach weg.
Ich kann gut nachvollziehen,
dass das Angst macht.
Es macht immer Angst,
wenn man Grundpfeiler der Weltsicht
infrage stellt.
Ich weiss, was ich erlebt habe.
Ich weiss, was ich daraus mitnehme.
Das zählt für mich, meine Meinung.
Die anderen Meinungen sind mir egal.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Halluzinationen schweifen.
Die docken manchmal
bei irgendetwas an,
das man vorher gerade erlebt hat.
Das ist wie bei Träumen:
Es hat irgendeinen Fetzen
in den Träumen,
den man an dem Tag oder vorher
gerade erlebt hat.
Aber eine Nahtoderfahrung
ist unvergleichbar intensiver.
Marcel Gasser hielt sich als Hauswart
und Einmann-Putzbetrieb über Wasser.
Dann kam das Coronavirus und ihm
brachen fast alle Einnahmen weg.
Schlussendlich ist man
zufrieden mit dem, was man hat.
Man versucht,
sich damit zu arrangieren.
Ich denke, dass es anderen Familien
oder Leuten auch so geht.
Darum wollen wir nicht jammern.
Weil ihm
sein verstorbener Vater sagte,
seine Zeit sei noch nicht gekommen,
geht Marcel Gasser davon aus,
dass er auf dieser Welt
noch gebraucht werde.
Vielleicht ist das meine Aufgabe:
für die Leute da zu sein,
die Hilfe brauchen
und ihnen diese Hilfe auch zu geben.
Und wer hilft Ihnen?
- Ich mir selber.
Vielleicht ist das etwas,
das auch schwierig ist:
selber Hilfe zu holen.
Damit tue ich mich z.B. schwer.
Ich sage mir:
Ich bin erwachsen, Familienvater.
Ich habe eine Verantwortung.
Ich muss doch selber dafür sorgen,
dass ich da rauskomme.
Dass er nicht weiss,
wie er und seine Familie
in den kommenden Monaten
über die Runden kommen sollen,
setzt ihm zu, auch wenn er versucht,
es sich nicht anmerken zu lassen.
Finanzielle Sorgen
begleiten ihn schon ein Leben lang.
Er hat immer gearbeitet
und nie viel verdient.
Aber so schlimm wie jetzt
war es noch selten:
Er steht vor dem Nichts.
Gab es je einen Moment,
wo Sie es bereuten,
dass Sie zurückgekommen sind?
- Nein. Nein.
Oh nein,
das Leben ist viel zu schön.
Ich bin froh, zurückgekommen zu sein
und das alles erleben zu dürfen,
die Kinder aufwachsen zu sehen.
Guten Appetit!
* Ruhige Musik *
Die haben da draussen
ja einen Reitparcours gemacht.
Ramon Gartmann ist Ende 30
und mit Selina verheiratet,
mit der er zwei kleine Kinder hat.
Sie verbringen
so viel Zeit wie möglich zusammen,
machen fast alles gemeinsam.
Mehr brauche er nicht
zu seinem Glück.
Oh!
Ich fühle mich voll lebendig
mit meiner Familie,
v.a. mit den Kindern.
Also nein, auch mit dir.
Ich habe von den Kindern
so viel gelernt, das meine ich.
Einfach im Augenblick zu sein.
Das hat auch viel
mit dieser Erfahrung zu tun.
Dort habe ich gelernt, was
es heisst, voll im Moment zu sein.
Bitte dort drin, nicht hier!
Schau!
Achtung!
Was soll ich machen?
- Dass hier aufhacken.
Wir machen das Beet für Nüsslisalat
bereit.
Seine Nahtoderfahrung
machte ihm bewusst,
wie schnell alles enden kann.
Irgendwann wird der Tod kommen.
Vielleicht erst im hohen Alter -
aber vielleicht auch schon morgen.
Ja, wenn ich merken würde,
dass ich entscheiden kann,
ob ich gehen will oder nicht, würde
ich auf jeden Fall hierbleiben.
Wenn der Punkt kommen würde,
an dem ich merke,
dass es einfach so ist,
würde ich mich dem sicher hingeben.
Aber ich geniesse es schon mega.
Das Leben ist schön.
Marcel Gasser muss einen
weiteren Schicksalsschlag verkraften:
Er hatte vor wenigen Tagen
einen Schlaganfall.
Als Sie realisierten, was passiert
ist und wie knapp es vielleicht war:
Fährt einem das ein?
- Also, ja ...
Wie schnell es ...
... fertig sein könnte.
Äh ...
Dass man die Frau
plötzlich nicht mehr sieht
oder die Kinder
nicht mehr sehen kann.
Aber ich glaube,
es war nicht einmal das, sondern ...
... mehr die Angst,
dass man danach bleibende ...
... Schäden hat oder man
ein Pflegefall werden könnte.
Das ...
... war eher das, das mich mehr ...
... belastet hat,
als dass es fertig sein könnte.
Wann es fertig ist,
wissen wir ja nicht.
Haben Sie Angst vor dem Tod?
Nein, ich habe keine Angst
vor dem Tod, im Gegenteil.
Ich übe mich oft im Sterben.
Ich gehe noch einmal zurück
in das Erlebnis.
Ich weiss, dass ich in dem Moment,
in dem ich sterbe ...
... loslassen kann.
Dann ist es einfach okay.
Man ist nicht alleine,
wenn man stirbt.
Man wird abgeholt.
Und das ist so tröstlich.
Auch das Gefühl, dass der Schmerz ab
einem gewissen Zeitpunkt wegfällt,
weil das Bewusstsein sich öffnet.
Ich denke, wenn das Präludium
schon so faszinierend
und fantastisch ist ...
... kann das Konzert danach
nur noch schöner sein.
Wir haben schon Angst davor, den Job
zu wechseln oder den Wohnort.
Da wechselt man alles, was man hat,
sein komplettes Dasein.
Alles, das ganze Leben, dieses
Konstrukt, das man aufgebaut hat,
muss man loslassen.
Ich glaube, das ist immer schwierig.
Ich freue mich eigentlich
auf den Tod,
obwohl ich ihn jetzt
noch nicht will.
Ich lebe noch sehr gerne und hoffe,
dass das
noch nicht so schnell kommt.
Aber der Tod ist sicher
ein grossartiger Übergang,
wo sich in dem Moment dann die
Rätsel des Universums entschlüsseln.
Gut möglich allerdings,
dass uns auf Erden
noch viel Dunkelheit erwartet,
bevor uns im Jenseits
das Licht empfängt.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021